and right now american families are
paying around 500 more each month for
basic necessities and bills compared to
last year on the same income yes that's
why we've connected with our savings
expert for some helpful hacks to keep
more money in your wallet
most of us sign up for auto pay on our
monthly bills but it's time to
scrutinize those bills to make sure you
aren't paying for unnecessary services
add-ons or unused subscriptions this
could be something as simple as
setting up overdraft protection on your
bank so you're not paying that overdraft
fee what about an extra dvr box in your
cable plan that you're not using maybe
in the guest room or even premium movie
channels that your family really isn't
watching budgeting expert andrea warwick
says compare rates so you don't miss out
on savings when it comes to cable
internet and insurance with the
zebra.com you can even get help
negotiating your bills using sites like
bill shark
paying down high interest credit card
debt will free up money in your monthly
budget but you may not have that extra
cash to make that happen so here's an
alternative you can consolidate that by
transferring your balance to a zero
percent balance transfer card this is
going to essentially waive any interest
you pay on that debt for 12 to 21 months
helping you save a lot of money and
helping you pay down that debt go to
cardrates.com to find the best one that
fits your needs and don't forget about
unique ways to boost that cash flow
getting paid to share your opinions
taking online surveys at sites like
surveyjunkie.com or swagbucks.com
get paid about twenty dollars an hour to
offer virtual tutoring on nights and
weekends through varsitytutortutors.com
you can run odd jobs around town whether
it's building furniture or gardening
through sites like taskrabbit.com
she also recommends you shop for
groceries carefully do your meal
planning use the flip app to know which
stores have the best prices for the
items on your shopping list and look for
the manager markdowns on meat fish and
poultry nearing their expiration date to
save you about 70 percent